ارتفاعه مقاعد الجمهوريين في النواب الى
208 مقابل
288 للديمقراطيين فيفا جورجيا تؤجل خصم
شيوخ
احتجاجات الليليه في ايران
قائد العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا يصف
بالصعب قراره سحب الجيش من خرسان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم واسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير كشفت
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه عن
تقدم طفيف للجمهوريين على الديمقراطيين
حتى الان فيما تم الاعلان عنه النتائج في
مجلس الشيوخ الجمهوريه
48 وذلك بعد ان فاز الجمهوريون بولايه
واسكندر
مقاعد في مجلس الشيوخ غير محسومه هي
جورجيا اريزونا
الديمقراطيون عبر الحالي على الجمهوريه
اما الحصمه الحقيقي
وفي الاخيره يتقدم الجمهوريه ادم لاكس اوت
على السيره الردمقراطي الحاليه
التي يبدو انها ستخسر مقعدها اما في
جورجيا في السباق قريب للغايه بين سيناتور
الديمقراطيه الحالي
للانتخابات في السادس من ديسمبر 2008
[موسيقى]
سبونج بوب
في ولاياتنا سينتقل الى السادس من ديسمبر
المقبل وهو سباق على مقعد عضو مجلس الشيوخ
بين رفاييل
لجوله الاعاده
حتى يوم الاثنين الموافق الثامن والعشرين
من نوفمبر
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الامريكي
جديده النصفيه كانت نصرا كبيرا جدا
بالنسبه للجمهوريين وقال انه اذا فاز
الجمهوريون في انتخابات الكونجرس يجب ان
ينسب الفضل اليه
هو العكس
من جهتي اكد الرئيس الامريكي انه مستعد
للعمل مع الجمهوريه لضمان الامن المصالح
الامريكيه بغض النظر عن نتائج الانتخابات
النصفيه شهدت افضل اداء للحزب الديمقراطي
منذ سنوات طويله الموجه الحمراء التي تنبا
بها الجمهوريون في انتخابات التشديد
النصفي لم تحدث ونتائج حتى اللحظه مخالفه
لما توقعه الاعلام والجمهوريون وانا مستعد
للعمل مع جمهوريين للضمان امن المصالح
الامريكيه بغض النظر عن نتائج الانتخابات
وساعمل مع الجميع لخدمه الشعب الامريكي
وسادع قاده الحزبين الاجتماعي في البيت
الابيض لمناقشته كيفيه العمل معا
وقال بعدين انه ينوي الترشحه لولايه
الرئاسيه الثانيه في عام 20 24 بغض النظر
عن نتائج انتخابات التجديد نصفين مشيرا
الى ان قراره النهائيه عما اذا كان سيترشح
ام لا سيكون في مطلع العام القادمه
كما عاد باقي اليوم كده على حسابه في
تويتر بان انتخابات هذا العام تمثل افضل
انتخابات النصفيه منذ عام
واضاف لقد خسرنا عددا اقل من المقاعد في
مجلس النواب ومقارنه باول انتخابات
النصفيه لرئيس الديمقراطي منذ 40 عاما على
الاقل
نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه ستحمله معها على
ما يبدو رياحه تغيير ستعيده رسم سياسات
الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
واخيرا ورغم تهديد الجيش الايراني
في مناطق مختلفه حيث تم ترديد شعارات
النيران في صور
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كما تعرضت مقرات المسج فيها مدان وشهر
لهاجمات بالمولتو
[موسيقى]
وافضلي تواصلوا وتمدد الاحتجاجات ضد
النظام دعوه
الداخليه الناتجه عن الاحتجاجات التي بدات
قبل اسابيع في عقابه مقتل الشابه محسن
امين
عقد حواري فعال على المستوى الوطني للخروج
من المسجد
كشفت منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود ان ايران
تحاول بشكل
نساء من خلال توقيف عدد غير مسبوق من
الصحفيات في حملتها ضد الاحتجاجات بعد
وفاه سامي
من احتجازي النشاط الى الصحفيه استراتيجيه
يتبعها النظام الايراني لقمع منعلت
اصواتهم داخليا ضد ممارسته بشكل منهجي
بحسب منظمه مراسلون بلا حدود تحاول ايران
جاهده اسكت النساء من خلال توقيف عدد غير
مسبوقا من الصحفيات في حملتها ضد
الاحتجاجات على مقتل مهسا امينه
المنظمه اوضحت ايضا ان حوالي نصف الصحفيين
الذين قبض عليهم اخيرا هم من النساء من
بينهن اثنتان تواجهان عقوبه الاعدام اذ
وجهت السلطات الايرانيه الاتهام الى
نيلوفير حامدي والى هي محمدي وهما صحفيتا
كانتا من اول من لفت الانتباه الى وفاه
امي بتهمه الدعايه ضد النظام والتامل ضد
الامن القومي وهما تهمتان قد تؤديان الى
عقوبه الاعدام
[موسيقى]
افعال تكشف الستاره عن نوايا النظام
الايراني في قمع الاحتجاجات التي تهدد
قبضتها على السلطه فيما تعلو مطالبات
عديده بضروره اطلاق سراح الصحفييتين دون
قيد او شرط
احتجاجات تخطط جراتها ما تعتبرها السلطات
الايرانيه خطوط حمرا 42 صحفيا على الاقل
في كل انحاء ايران اوقفوا منذ انطلاق
الاحتجاجات افرج عن ثمانيه منهم ولا
تزالوا 15 صحفيه من بين 34 صحفيا
رهن الاحتجاز
من جانبه قال رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شارب
ميشيل ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث في الوقت
الراهب
مزيدا من العقوبات ضد سلطات الايرانيه
المسؤوله عن قمع الاحتجاجات وخلال كلمه
الله امام البرلماني الاوروبي
الايرانيه ضد المظاهرات السلبيه
اضافيه الايراني
اخونا سليمان
[تصفيق]
هناك اقتراح باقامه الدفاع على الضفه
اليسرى لنهر ديني برو افهم انه قرار صعب
للغايه لكن في الوقت نفسه والاهم انقاذ
ارواح جيشنا والحفاظ على القدره القتاليه
العامه لهذه المجموعه
في واحده من اكبر عمليه الانسحاب الروسي
التي قد تشكل نقطه تتحول في حرب تقترب من
نهايه شهرها التاسع موسكوت توجه قواتها
بترك الضفه اليمنى لنهر ديني برو في منطقه
خرسنا الاوكرانيه وتوجهي ساره وزير الدفاع
الروسي امر بتنفيذ الانسحاب اقتراح من
قائد العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا الجنرال
سيرجيو روفيكن الذي اقر بانه ليس قرارا
سهلا الخطوه الروسيه جاءت بعد تعرض خارج
لهجوم اوكرانيا مضاد منذ اسابيع ان شهدت
مواجهات ضاريه في الايام الاخيره
عليها الرؤوس في اوكرانيا بالكامل منذ
اطلاق العمليات العسكريه في الرابع
والعشرين من فبراير الماضي
وكانت الى جانب ثلاث مناطق اوكرانيه اخرى
ضمتها اليها موسكو بعد استفتاء لقي
انتقادات دوليه واسعه في وقت ابدا فيه
الكريم لان استعداده للتفاوض مع اكياف لكن
مع مراعاه الحقائق في الوقت الراهن حقائق
بدات تتغير مثل ما حدث في خرسان بلال
الوجداني العربيه
الجيش الروسيه الاربعاء
ده الفورماتين مبروك
عواطفنا دائما اثناء الحرب بالتاكيد لن
نفيد العدو بكل تفاصيل عملياتنا سواء في
الجنوب او في الشرق او في اي مكان اخر
عندما نجني النتائج سيرى الجميع ذلك
القوات الروسيه من محاوله تفجير محطه
الطاقه الكهرومائيه
واعتبر ذلك بمثابه
من اي محاوله لتفجير محطه
الكهرومائيه واغرق اراضينا وتجفيه في محطه
النوويه سيعني ذلك اعلان الحربي
بعد ذلك
قال رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه
الجنرال مارك ميلي ان الجيش الروسي تكبد
خسائر بشريه تقدر باكثر من 100 الف جندي
سقطوا بين قتيل وجريح في اوكرانيا
عانت على الارجح من مصر من الخسائر في
الحرب
الانسانيه التي تسببت بها الحرب في
اوكرانيا
قال رئيس الحكومه البريطانيه ريشه هناك
استقالته
التي لم يكن على علم بها قبل تعيينه كانت
صائبه بينما يجري تحقيق فيها
وصفات المعارضه
جلسه مسائله هناك الثالثه في البرلمان قد
تكون الاصعب بعد اضطرار الوزيري جبن وليم
سنت المعين في الحكومه من دون حقيبه الى
ترك منصبه بسبب اتهامات بالتنمر وارسال
رسائل غير مقبوله لاحد اعضاء حزبه زعيم
المعارضه العماليه وجه ثلاثه اسئله محرجه
لسناك انتقد فيها تعامله مع قضيه وليامسن
وخشيته من مواجهه الناس في انتخابات عامه
هل انت نادم على قرار تعيينه وزيرا في
الحكومه رد سوناك بشكل واضح والصريح انه
نادم على اعادته الى مجلس الوزراء
اوبليفر من الواضح انني اسف لتعيين شخص
اضطر الى الاستقاله في هذه الظروف لكني
اعتقد ان ما يود الشعب البريطاني ان يعرفه
هو انه عندما تظهر مثل هذه المواقف سيتم
التعامل معها بشكل صحيح وهذا هو السبب
استقالته واتمام اجراء تحقيق للنظر في هذه
الامور بشكل صحيح وكما قلت ان حكومه ستتسم
بالنزاهه والاحترافيه والمسؤوليه
[تصفيق]
كانت واضحه من النواب المعارضين لاعتبارهم
ان الحكومه لم تلتزم بمعيارنا نزاهه
والمسؤوليه في قضيه و سلم وهم يطالبون
بتقديم تقرير كامل عن سبب اعاده تعيينه
وزيرا هذا في وقتناك المزيد من الضغوط على
خلفيه التعيين سوى وزيره الداخليه بعد
ايام من اقالتها لانتها قواعد وزاريه
الهجوم على سوناك لم يقتصر على تعيناته بل
شمله ايضا عادما فرض ضرائب اضافيه على
ارباح شركات الطاقه غير المتوقعه الى جانب
عدم الغاء ميزه الاعفاء الضريبي على الدخل
الاجنبي رئيس الحكومه رئيس السوناك يحاول
الا تلحق استقالته باضرار اعمقه
لكن المعارضه التي تضع كل قراراته تحت
مجها لن تتوانى عن ملاحقه كل صغيره وكبيره
على صله بحكمته من اعاده تعيينه وزيره
الداخليه بره من وصولا الى قراراته بشان
المساعدات والضرائب مصطفى زارو العربيه
لندن
وصفاتها
ان اسرائيل نفذت قارات جويه في شرق سوريا
استهدفت قافله مركبات يشبه في تهريبها
اسلحه ايرانيه بعد ان عبرت الحدود من
العراق
[موسيقى]
عاد قطاع النفط السوري الى الواجهه بعد
دخول الحرب في سوريا عامها الثاني عشر
للسيطره على امكانيات سوريا النفطيه سمحا
للمصلحين المحليين واثرياء الحرب والخصوم
بتعاون معا للاستحواذ على ما تبقى من
ثروات نفط البلاد وعائداتها
[موسيقى]
قالت سلطات الكرديه عدد النساء والاطفال
الاجانب من تنظيم داعش الذين استعدتهم دول
هم من مخيمات الاحتجاز شمال شرق سوريا سجل
رقما قياسيا هذا العام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حضرت الحكومه الالمانيه
شراء شركه سويديه تملكها مجموعه صينيه
وزاره الاقتصاد الالمانيه
لان شراء المصنع قد يعرض النظام والامن في
المانيا
تم اغلاق مفعل في محطه طاقه النوويه جنوب
السويد بشكل غير متوقع بعد عطل في احد
التوربينات حسب ما اعلنتيات السويديه
الرسميه
واوضحت
المتحدثه باسم المحطه ان المفاعل او ان
المفاعله ثالث في محطه اوسكار شامل للطاقه
النوويه فصل عن شبكه الطاقه بسبب توقف
التوربين وان العمل جار لحل المشكله
كشفت وكاله الاتحاد الاوروبي الى اللجوء
ان عدد المتقدمين للحصول على الحمايه
الدوليه في اوروبا وصل الى مستويات كبيره
لم تشهدها القاره منذ الوجوه اكثر من
مليون شخص اليها قبل سبع سنوات
الف شخص تقدموا بطلبات اللجوء في اغسطس
الماضي في 27 دوله عضو في الاتحاد
الاوروبي في مطالب حوالي 2005
بزياده تصل الى 16% مقارنه بشهر
علقوا في البحر اكثر من اسبوعين سفينه
انقاذ تقل اكثر من 200 مهاجره رفضت
ايطاليا استقبالهم على سواحلها
الان سوبر جزيره كورسيكا الفرنسيه
الوصول الى اقرب ميناء امن وهو ما لم
تحترمه ايطاليا على اعتبار ان المهاجرين
الذين تم انقاذهم كانوا في مياه الاقليم
رئيس منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس على تقديم
المساعدات الغذائيه الطبيه الفوريه الى
منطقه تجري شمال اثيوبيا على وجه السرعه
بعد وقف اطلاق النار المتفق عليه بعد
عامين من الحرب مشيرا في الوقت ذاته الى
ضروره اعاده فتح الخدمات الاساسيه مثل
الخدمات المصرفيه والاتصالات وغيرها في
الاقليمي
الفوري للاغذيه والادويه وايضا بالطبع
اعاده فتح الخدمات الاساسيه مثل البنوك
والاتصالات وغيرها
اعلنت مجموعته التي تضم شركات فيسبوك
وانستغرام واتساب عن تسريحات 13% من
موظفيها حول العالم
بعد قرار رئيس الشركه مركز
العامه
في مواجهه تيك توك التي تتصاعد بقوه في
عالم الشبكات الاجتماعيه الى جانب تراجع
عدد من المولين الرقميين عن الانفاق على
منصات الشركه بسبب ارتفاع معدلات التضخم
وعدم استقرار الاسواق عمليه تسريحتها تعد
الاكبر من نوعها في تاريخ الشركه عدد
موظفها 87 الفنا وهو ما دفع مارك زوكربيرج
الى مخاطبه الموظفين في الرساله
وكيف وصلنا الى اعرف ان هذا صعب على
الجميع وانا اسف بشكل خاص للمتاثرين
قرارات اضافيه تتجه مثل اتخاذها وفق بيان
مركز كربرج من بينها ان تصبح الشركه اصغر
حجما واكثر كفاءه من خلال خفض الانفاق الى
جانب تمديد قرار وقف عمليات التوظيف
وفقا لخبراء فان قرارات ذكربيرج تتعرضوا
معانيه زياده الانفاق والتوسع في بناء
عالم متوفرز الافتراضي والاستثمار في
ادواته التقنيه
نهج جديد في اداره كبرى شركات التكنولوجيه
العملاقه قد يلحق بركبه اخرون لكنه في
الوقت ذاته يعكس اختبارا صعبا ورهانا قد
تظهر نتائجها اما الخروج من الازمه او
مزيدا من القرارات الصعبه
علي السمان العربيه
غير حكوميه خدمات
تكنولوجيا وتطوره للكشف عن التغيرات التي
تحدث في الغابات مثل تراجع المساحاتها
والحرائق التي تنشب فيها
يقع خارج مناطق الغابات الرسميه
[موسيقى]
بدل عمال في اليونان اضرابا يستمر 24 ساعه
مطالبين بزياده الاجور لمواجهه التضخم في
الوقت الذي يبدا ارتفاعه اسعار الطاقه
وتكلفه المعيشه في اوروبا الى اضرابات
واحتجاجات العماليه في انحاء القاره
وشارك الالف في مسيره في اثينا ضمن ثاني
اضراب هذا العام احتجاجا على ارتفاع
تكاليف المعيشه
قال المدير الاقليمي منطقه الشرق الادنى
والاوسط في اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
في بيزو كاربوني ان خطرا انتشار الاصابه
بالكوليرا ولسان الحاد في سوريا ولبنان
يمثل عبئا جديدا يفاقم معاناه الناس في
هذين البلدين اللذين يعانيان حاليا بما
فيه الكفايه مع تاكيد ان هناك حاجه بس
لايجاد حلول اكثر اصتدامه لتعزيز قدره
البنيه تحتيه الحيوي على الصمود
ايضا الى ان هذه المجتمعات هي التي
انظمه رعايه الصحيه وانظمه المياه والصرف
الصحي التي باتت على شفل